Standing in the dark
staring into a mirror
summoning Bloody Mary
by chanting her name
is a terrifying classic
sleepover ritual.
Here's the basic premise.
If you chant "Bloody Mary"
while looking in a mirror
in a dark room,
preferably a bathroom,
the face of this spectral woman
will appear alongside you.
The mirror is a symbol of
revelation and self-reflection.
It forces us to see
what others see.
In fiction,
mirrors and reflections
often serve as tools
for confrontation like in
"Harry Potter" or "Snow White."
Even when serving as portals
or windows to
alternative worlds,
like an "Alice Through the
Looking Glass" or "Oculus,"
the journey of self-discovery
or revelation is paramount.
[dramatic music]
With Bloody Mary,
that truth might just
be a good fright,
or her appearance might tell
your future, grant you a wish,
or perhaps even kill you.
I'm Dr. Emily Zarka
and this is "Monstrum."
If you were unlucky enough
to summon Bloody Mary,
there's no real standard
of what you'll see.
By some accounts, she's
hideously mutilated,
but in others, she is
beautiful but bloody.
More commonly though,
every aspect of her
appearance is vague.
Her spectral origin story
is all over the place too.
She's tragically disfigured
and out for revenge
or she's been killed
by a jealous lover.
There's even versions where
she was a witch burned
at the stake in Salem.
In some legends,
she's connected to a cult.
Where she comes from
and what she looks like
is less important than the
ritual that summons her.
Three things are
almost always required,
a dark room, a
mirror, and a chant.
You have to say
her name anywhere
from three to 100 times,
and in some accounts, you must
have a single candle burning.
In others, the summoning
must occur in a bathroom.
A few tales even specify
you have to run water,
flush the toilet, or
spin around three times.
Still others note
that you must run out
of the room when you see her
or she can cause you harm.
And in some versions
of the legend,
you even have to
offer your own blood.
What happens from there?
She might reveal your future,
but in most stories
she's threatening.
She will frighten you out of
the room or even attack you
in the real world.
In one particularly
gruesome variation,
if you touch the mirror,
she'll be able to drag you
into her realm and kill you.
Sound ambiguous?
Yeah, that's kind of the
point, at least in my mind.
Not knowing exactly
what is going to happen
or who is going to appear
in the mirror is part
of the attraction
of this legend, and a
reason to try it yourself.
There are three common
elements to the legend.
Let's break it down.
First, the dark room.
Fact, it's scary
to be in the dark,
especially if you're asking
for something
supernatural to happen.
Our eyes tend to play
tricks on us in the dark.
Seeing a distorted
reflection in the mirror is
possible when darkness and
flickering light are in play.
In the case of Bloody Mary,
overall spookiness and fear
are common culprits too.
Second, the mirror.
Mirrors serve as
symbolic boundaries,
spaces where the
real is confronted
while offering the possibility
of alternative ways
of seeing or being.
After all, there is the
idea of the mirror realm.
The basic concept
of the mirror realm
is that there is an opposite,
usually darker world that
exists alongside our own.
And mirrors serve as the
portals between the two.
Even before bloody Mary
entered into the picture,
the idea existed that
with some kind of ritual,
otherworldly figures could
appear inside of mirrors.
In some lore,
a malicious magic practitioner
could even bind a spirit
or the devil to a mirror.
As a threat of real persecution
for witchcraft declined,
the idea of a cult play
or lighthearted dabbling
in a cult and magical
practices rose in popularity.
Young adults,
particularly women,
turned to the mirror
for divination rituals,
often with the intention of
identifying their future spouse.
Knowledge of these playful
rituals was popular enough
that in the early 20th century,
as the postcard industry boomed,
cards depicting women engaging
in divination
rituals were popular
during the fall season, often
corresponding to Halloween.
In one example,
a girl stands in front of
mirrors holding a candle
while the nebulous face
of a handsome male figure
appears over her shoulder.
But not all cards show
such appealing prospects.
Other versions show
a stereotypical witch
or the frightening
ghost of a man.
Connecting the
mirror ritual back
to its more nefarious
associations.
It's hard to guess
how seriously rituals
like these were taken.
Although the playful
commodification of the events
suggests at least some level
of carefree participation.
The mirror ritual offers a form
of boundary rebellion with
little risk of true danger,
an appealing prospect
for teenagers.
And finally, the chant,
or what puts the
Mary in Bloody Mary.
The repeated name is
always a female one,
Bloody Mary of course,
but also Mary Worth,
Mary Ruth, Black Madame,
Mary Lou, Mary Johnson,
Mary Weather, and Mary
Whales, for example.
Mary is a common name,
but some of these
women stand out
more than others in folklore.
Take Mary Worth, for example,
said to have a disfigured face
either from genetics
or a bad accident,
she resented her looks.
So much so that she put
a curse upon the mirror
she gazed into one day, and
it shattered, killing her.
If you stare into a mirror
and summon Mary Worth,
she will appear at a distance
in the reflection moving closer
and closer until she
shatters the mirror.
And if this happens,
you'll never again be
able to look into a mirror
without seeing her reflection.
Or there's Mary Whales.
This Mary was a young
woman who was killed
when she was run
over by a truck.
Six years after she died,
a couple saw her
trying to hitchhike.
Bleeding and wet, she had
scratches on her face.
You can look in a mirror and
summon her ghost by saying
"I do believe in Mary Whales"
somewhere between
10 or 100 times.
Given the hitchhiking
ghost element,
this urban legend might
be a regional variant
combining elements of
other legends and monsters,
like the vanishing hitchhiker,
La Llorona, or Mary Worth.
And let's address the
royal elephant in the room.
Only one other female figure
in history has been
called Bloody Mary,
Mary Tudor or Queen Mary I.
Born to Katherine of Aragon
and King Henry VIII in 1516,
princess Mary was named
after her beautiful aunt,
an attribute she came to embody.
Scorned by her father
upon his second marriage,
she would eventually be
declared his rightful heir
in his will and took
the throne in 1553.
Her reign was
fraught with tension.
At Mary's command,
hundreds of Protestants
were burned at the stake
as heretics.
Despite this violence,
it wasn't until her half
Sister Queen Elizabeth's rule
that she would become
known as Bloody Mary,
likely as an attempt to diminish
or at least tarnish her
historical significance.
The catchy name
gained popularity
as the 17th century wore on.
So by the time the infamous
mirror summoning postcards
popped up in the 20th century,
the nickname had been around
for hundreds of years.
To me, there seems to
be an easy connection
between the royal
and real Bloody Mary
and the folkloric monster.
Both of their stories deal
with the cultural
perception of beauty
and of stories being rewritten
by whomever is telling them,
casting the Marys as both
victims and villains.
When we consider
where the summoning
of Bloody Mary often occurs,
in bathrooms, and by
whom, young women,
another interpretation
becomes apparent.
Bathrooms are uniquely
liminal places.
Whether private or public,
they are rooms
within larger spaces
where private acts occur--
bodily functions often
seen as gross or taboo.
Folklorist Alan Dundes'
freudian reading of Bloody Mary
proposes a metaphorical
representation
to the onset of menstruation.
He argues that the
mirror summoning ritual
serves as a right of
passage into puberty,
a journey that is both
feared and celebrated.
If we accept this
reading of the legend,
then bloody Mary is a warning,
not only about the inevitability
of the sudden bleeding
women will likely deal with
in the bathroom,
but of puberty in general.
An adolescent girl gazing
in the mirror may be met
with both trepidation and wonder
at her own changing appearance.
And that's before you
factor in the pressures
of an entire beauty industry
dedicated to making her
want to alter the reflection
staring back at her.
Not to mention the expectations
of whatever standard
of attractiveness is being
promoted in culture at the time.
Perhaps then, it is
unsurprising that the Mary
in the mirror is always
frightening when summoned.
It also helps explain
why Bloody Mary
is a common figure
at sleepovers,
which often occur during puberty
and into the teen years.
Telling scary stories,
playing games,
and pulling pranks are
all common at sleepovers,
at least the ones I went to.
And Bloody Mary is an
option that can fit
into all three categories
for just the right age group.
It's worth noting
that the participant
in the Bloody Mary ritual
is always in control,
or appears to be.
They're the one
who says the name,
but they can also turn on
the lights or run away.
The ghost is summoned. It
does not simply appear.
Unlike other monstrous spectral
encounters or ghostly women
like the Banshee or La Llorona,
this notorious female
specter must be invited in,
which partially
diminishes her power,
or at least her reach,
and removes some of
Bloody Mary's potential
to cause terror.
So our ability to
control the appearance
of Bloody Mary takes a little
bit of the danger out of it.
Fear becomes fun.
The idea existed that with
some kind of ritual...
Some kind of ritual, pause.
(crew)
Rolling by the way, but...
Ooh, cut that.